Sarah is a sales professional who keeps
in touch with her contacts by email
instant messaging and online social
networks it's important to Sarah that
clients can easily connect with her
that's why she has tongle me on her
email signature public profiles
professional blog and business
cards John is Sarah's client they've
just connected on LinkedIn and now John
wants to schedule a call with Sarah
because Sarah has tongle me he simply
clicks to see when she's free he adds
some details picks a few times and sends
it only takes a minute and he doesn't
have to sign up he simply confirms his
email address and he's
done Sarah gets Jon's invitation by
email she picks from his proposed times
and books the call it's automatically
added to her calendar and John gets an
email confirmation to add to his
calendar and Sarah could have even
replied from her BlackBerry iPhone or
any other
smartphone it's so simple that Sarah now
uses tungle me everywhere she Skypes it
to clients twitters it to her followers
texts it to friends and business
associates emails it to new clients to
bookmark and has even installed the
tungle me Facebook app so that she and
her tungle friends on Facebook can
easily schedule meetings and see each
other's
availability it's a quick and easy way
for Sarah to let her connect to
her